valéry giscard d'estaing à lyon il faut
muscler l'économie française et
restaurer la responsabilité individuelle
avant son voyage à new york le président
de la république recevra la majorité
l'opposition pour discuter du
désarmement parti communiste lors de
l'examen de conscience
la réponse de georges marchais mercredi
commentaire alain duhamel tchad
valéry giscard d'estaing les forces
françaises n'exerceront aucune action
offensive à petits pas mais sûrement les
escargots chinois menacent les
gastéropodes bourguignon messieurs
bonsoir le président aux manettes pour
la deuxième fois en quelques mois le
chef de l'état a conduit lui-même la ram
inaugural d'un métro celui-là et orange
et c'est celui de la ville de lyon
enduite sans à coup on dit les
personnalités qui la transportait
pendant une dizaine de minutes
sunu contrôle éclairé d'un conducteur
professionnel celui là est le prénom
république en a profité pour annoncer
qu'un certain nombre de mesures
nouvelles en matière de transport
collectif serait examinée au cours d'un
prochain conseil des ministres
bernard pradinois suivi la journée
lyonnaise du président
les petits lyonnais ne sont pas allés à
l'école aujourd'hui pour cause
d'inauguration de métro il faisait beau
et il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
personnalité monsieur giscard d'estaing
un certain moment s'est mise au poste de
pilotage pour conduire lui même le métro
de lyon pendant quelques stations
au cours de la matinée on a vu souvent
le chef de l'état de discuter avec
monsieur hernu le maire socialiste de
villeurbanne pour monsieur hernu le pays
n'est pas en état de guerre civile et il
est bien normal qu'un des leaders du ps
reçoivent comptablement le président de
la république
enfin l'auditorium de la part vieux
monsieur giscard d'estaing a parlé de
lyon de son avenir international mais
aussi de la france et de son effort de
redressement économique
l'effort collectif d'une part la
responsabilité individuelle de l'autre
doivent être les deux ressorts de notre
rétablissement de ressorts associé de
ressort un briquet et tendus vers un
même résultat
faire ce soit ne signifie en aucune
manière renoncé à établir plus de
justice en france chacun a entendu ici
et partout pendant la campagne de cet
hiver l'immense aspirations des
françaises et des français et notamment
des plus jeunes vers davantage de
justice
une solidarité accrue avec les moins
favorisés s'impose particulièrement tu
autant de l'effort
c'est le sens des actions engagées
préparer ou annoncées par le
gouvernement
et puis on a beaucoup marqué une
conversation dans le métro entre valéry
giscard d'estaing et le socialiste
charles hernu on dit que le chef de
l'état lui aurait annoncé son intention
de s'entretenir avec les responsables de
la majorité et de l'opposition sur le
problème du désarmement
j'ajoute qu'il ya eu deux manifestations
à cette occasion d'abord des handicapés
qui ont demandé un métro accessible à
tous ce n'est pas le cas de celui de
lyon noël mamère l'a déjà évoqué dans
c'est la vie et puis celle des
800 salariés de manufrance venue de
saint-etienne des représentants de
l'entreprise stéphanoise ont été reçus
cet après midi par un collaborateur de
valéry giscard d'estaing manufrance fait
beaucoup de publicité en ce moment pour
relancer ses activités
venons en maintenant à la troisième et
dernière journée de la réunion du comité
central du parti communiste place du
colonel fabien
la réunion s'était poursuivie
aujourd'hui ce qui n'était pas prévu à
l'origine en raison du grand nombre
d'orateurs inscrits alors essayons de
faire le point lundi à melle est d'abord
est ce qu'il ya eu unanimité comme le
dit le parti communiste derrière georges
marchais l'air son rapport à écouter
pour parler franchement comme dirait
georges marchais il ya deux choses qui
sont certaines la première c'est quand
on met 120 personnes ensemble puisque je
m'étais centrale et 120 personnes ne
peuvent pas toutes être du même avis bon
la seconde c'est que compte tenu de la
façon dont est composé le comité central
c'est évidemment pas l'endroit a
privilégié la contestation au sein du
parti communiste
donc il est probable que cette fois-ci
surtout si on se fonde sur certains
précédents qui ont existé est probable
que cette fois ci dans leur façon
d'apprécier le rapport de le commenter
puisque vous savez chacun commente en
fonction de son département ou de sa
responsabilité
il est probable que les initiés à demi
mots qui étaient là comprenez bien que x
ou y était plutôt d'accord ou plutôt
réservé alors précisément cette
contestation a votre avis il va
s'accentuer dans les semaines à venir
saxo toujours sais rien parce que ce
serait difficile de s'accentuer beaucoup
dans la mesure où on n'avait jamais vu
une contestation aussi public que celle
qui a existé depuis plusieurs semaines
en revanche ce que je crois c'est
qu'elle va se poursuivre je crois
qu'elle va se poursuivre dans l'immédiat
parce qu'il me semble que pour les
contestataires notamment pour les
intellectuels pas seulement pour eux il
me semble qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé
vraiment toutes les réponses à ceux qui
aux questions qu'ils ont posées
ben dis donc sur le lait comme sur le
fonctionnement monsieur fonctionnement
interne du parti communiste ou bien sur
la stratégie que le parti communiste va
devoir adopter pour la suite ils ne
seront sûrement pas satisfait d'après
les papiers qu'ils avaient fait avant
alors ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième c'est que en réalité entre ce
comité central qui est très important et
puis la préparation du 23ème congrès qui
aura lieu au tout début de l'année
prochaine
il ne s'écoulera pas beaucoup de temps
et qu'en fait les communistes commençons
à préparer leur 23e congrès dès la
rentrée et on sait qu'il ya des tribunes
alors là qui cette fois ci sont prévues
par les statuts qui existe et donc
qu'ils discuteront tous donc en réalité
à mon avis la contestation continuera au
moins jusqu'au 23
alors change marché a beaucoup fustigé
les cons cette affaire il l'a aussi
beaucoup fustigé le parti socialiste est
là visiblement ça va continuer oui mais
là aussi ce qui est clair dans leur
rapport du rj marché et ce qui est
évident quand on lit la presse
communiste en ce moment c'est que en ce
qui concerne l'analyse des
responsabilités devant l'échec de la
gauche d'une part et d'autre part
l'analyse des relations aujourd'hui
entre partis communistes et parti
socialiste
il n'y a aucun élément nouveau de
modération tant s'en faut le parti comme
le dit georges marchais dit nous n'avons
aucune responsabilité dans la défaite de
la gauche c'est de la faute du parti
socialiste donc naturellement il va y
avoir la convention des partis
socialistes naturellement les relations
vont plutôt plutôt ses grilles alors
l'union de la gauche dans tout ça quelle
va être la stratégie du pc continue à
tout prix l'union de la gauche même
artificiel écoutez le problème du parti
communiste c'est que s'il est isolé il
est inefficace donc que je dirais que
compte tenu du mode de scrutin par
exemple que compte tenu de sa situation
politique en france il est contraint à
ne pas renoncer une stratégie d'union
simplement sa difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ne peut pas renoncer une
stratégie d'union et qu'en même temps il
a un partenaire qui est réticent et que
ce que georges marchais encore dit
avant-hier ne peut le rendre que plus
réticents à la position personnelle de
georges marchais maintenant au nom alors
que ce dont il a sûrement été un petit
peu contesté de même qu'il est probable
que à l'intérieur du bureau politique
même il ya dû avoir des discussions mais
la position de hors jeu marche comme
secrétaire général du parti communiste
veut paraît solide et je dirais même que
puisqu'on sait déjà que les communistes
auront un candidat aux élections
présidentielles en 1981 je serais
surtout très étonné que ça ne soit pas
lui suite de l'examen de conscience des
formations de gauche après leur échec
électoral
les radicaux de gauche maintenant le
mouvement est très discret entre deux
candidats à la succession de robert
fabre
le choix se fera dans trois semaines
entre michel crépeau et jacques
maroselli le président démissionnaire
robert fabre donc à désigner son dauphin
pour le remplacer ils préfèrent jacques
maroselli partisans d'une autonomie
totale du émerger au sein d'union de la
gauche
enfin un dernier partenaire le ps nous
l'évoquions à l'instant sa convention
nationale se réunit demain à huis clos à
paris et la discussion s'engagera sur la
base de deux textes seulement une lettre
de françois mitterrand aux militants et
puis une sorte de da dam dom la
contribution aux débats déposée par le
crs
en fait il ya beaucoup de courant et de
sukkur en parti socialiste qui ne
manqueront pas s'exprimer demain
au parti socialiste on ne parle pas de
tendance
on parle de courants de pensée les
courants de pensée s'incarne bien
souvent dans un homme et chacun a son
histoire autour de françois mitterrand
les conventionnels ou anciens membres de
la convention des institutions
républicaines
ils ont suivi françois mitterrand au
nouveau parti socialiste lors du congrès
d'epinay en 1971
depuis huit nouveaux adhérents les ont
rejoints ensemble ils constituent ce que
l'on appelle les mitterrandistes les
anciens de la et ses filles oh ils sont
apportées au parti socialiste lors de sa
création le gros de ses troupes et sa
base ouvrière de grandes fédérations
celle du nord animée par pierre mauroy
et celle des bouches du rhône animé par
gaston defferre
le crs centre d'études de recherche et
d'éducation socialiste il a été créé du
temps de la cfi au par une équipe de
jeunes loups groupés autour de jean
pierre chevènement le crs aile gauche du
parti socialiste a d'abord soutenu
françois mitterrand depuis 1975
ils constituent la minorité du parti
socialiste les anciens du pays sus ils
ont rejoint le parti socialiste avec
michel rocard à l'automne 1974 en même
temps d'ailleurs que des syndicalistes
ils appartiennent à la majorité du parti
mais de plus en plus on les désigne sous
le nom de rocardien la tâche du parti
socialiste pour les mois qui viennent
réaliser l'unité entre ses hommes et
l'unité entre ses courants de pensée
autour d'un projet proprement socialiste
lettre de l'unité la publication
quotidienne du ps répète que le parti
communiste porte la responsabilité
fondamentale de l'échec de la gauche aux
législatives suite des élections
professionnelles dans les entreprises à
l'usiné renault du mans la cgt ce
maintien d'un premier collège celui des
ouvriers mais régressent très nettement
dans le second celui des cadres
manifestation aujourd'hui à marseille
des ouvriers de l'usiné terrains occupés
depuis hier le travail a repris à
l'usiné cela va de besançon le directeur
soviétique de l'entreprise a donc
accepté les conditions des ouvriers
français
et puis un nouveau démenti valéry
giscard d'estaing propos de la bombe à
neutrons ni expérience ni programmation
a dit le chef de l'état qui a par
ailleurs expliqué pour nos confrères de
tf1
la position française dans l'événement
du tchad dont jeu dans ce dispositif
bien entendu nos moyens à aucun moment
n'exerce exerceront d'actions offensives
ce n'est en aucune manière le rôle leur
mission est une mission de sécurité par
contre aussi longtemps que le
cessez-le-feu sera mise en question il
est normal que cette sécurité soit
assurée le parti communiste à protester
contre l'engagement français au tchad
propose maintenant un aperçu assez
rapide mais intéressant des métiers qui
montent c'est le nouvel économiste qui
publie cette semaine une enquête à
l'intention des huit cent mille jeunes
qui arrivent chaque année sur le marché
du travail commençait bien
mais par quoi bien des professions
autrefois prestigieuses ont cessé d'être
des débouchés aussi solides
qu'auparavant
comme le montre le nouvel économiste le
prestige d'une profession n'est pas tout
encore faut-il qu'elles ne soient pas
saturé prenons les professions libérales
d'émetteurs français seront 140 milles
dans dix ans il est peu probable que
tous puissent vivre aussi bien que les
30000 des années 50
même remarque pour les architectes pour
les avocats et surtout pour les
informaticiens cette profession pourtant
tout neuf est déjà actuellement
complètement saturé en revanche on a de
plus en plus besoin de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs dans l'industrie enfin de
nombreux métiers de l'artisanat commence
à retrouver une deuxième jeunesse et
donc des débouchés une enquête qui peut
aider les jeunes à se méfier des
professions attirante mais saturé et à
chercher du travail
là où il y en a très rapidement quelques
nouvelles de l'étranger le priant daoud
aurait été tué à coups de revolver en
afghanistan pendant le putsch dont nous
vous parlions hier il semble que les
combats ne soit pas terminé prises
d'otages en autriche un gangster retient
une douzaine d'employés de clients dans
une banque
et si je vous en parle c'est qu'il se
dit appartenir aux brigades rouges mais
apparemment la police autrichienne n'y
crois pas beaucoup à rome précisément
rien nouveau dans l'enlèvement de
monsieur aldo moro pas un seul signe des
terroristes
enfin au danemark abolition de la peine
de mort a décidé le parlement cet
après-midi supprimer une première fois
en 1920 la peine capitale avait été
rétabli après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
et puis il faut que nous développions
cette information qui nous a émus et
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
une jeune fille de 15 ans florence
enceinte de 10 semaines qui s'est
suicidé samedi dernier à villeneuve
saint georges saint georges par dont
près de paris parce que selon sa famille
elle n'avait pas pu réunir en argent
liquide
la somme nécessaire un avortement
thérapeutique matinales radio
alors cette information je la prends
avec toutes les précautions nécessaires
car je n'ai pas plus que vous de
précision l'instant nous n'avons plus
que je gardais de faire des liens
directs entre possibilités d'avortement
suicides
lorsque je n'en sais pas plus que vous
là dessus on découvre quand même à
l'occasion cette affaire c'est que il
faut payer pour un avortement
oui ça n'est pas remboursé par la
sécurité sociale et la loi a prévu que
l'on devait payer c'est tout à fait
légal de payer et de payer normalement
une somme qui est assez modique et aux
alentours de 700 francs et la jeune
fille n'avait qu'un sens oui enfin lavé
500 francs mais elle avait
l'autorisation de ses parents ce qui est
important puisque quand on a 15 ans on
ne peut pas avorter sans l'autorisation
de ses parents par un mois le laver mais
il ya aussi un délai qui est celui de
dix semaines je crois que c'est très
important effectivement de d'apporter le
plus tôt possible quand on doit le faire
et là elle était à la limite sur le jour
ma famille je crois aussi que ça c'est
un point important à dire lorsque cette
décision doit être prise de tête reprise
vite lorsque je voudrais dire m'éloigner
un tout petit peu ciblées pour faire un
point très léger sur la loi on pourrait
dire que quatre ans après bon c'est vrai
n'est pas parfait et elle n'est pas
forcément accessible à tout mais dans
l'ensemble
disons que cela ne se passe pas si mal
qu'on veut bien le dire
il ya encore des départements où un
certain nombre de médecins refusent il
reste un gros problème d'argent
car comme vous le savez les avortements
se font dans le public ou dans le privé
alors là je crois qu'on peut dire que de
nombreuses cliniques ont fait de petites
fortunes avec l'avortement et on ne peut
pas considérer que j'ai tout à fait
moral la jeune fille s'était d'ailleurs
et celle de pluie ni où ils avaient
refusé alors je voudrais surtout en
profiter pour dire que c'est avant tout
un problème d'information d'avant
l'avortement il faut le rappeler toutes
les femmes n'est pas une méthode de
contraception c'est un pis-aller
quand la contraception ne peut pas avoir
lieu ou n'a pas eu lieu pour des raisons
sociales ou familiales
et puis quand une femme est en détresse
je crois qu'il faut qu'elle sache
qu'elle peut s'adresser à un centre
dette sociale ou à la fois on peut lui
donner l'argent nécessaire pour avorter
si c'est nécessaire ou pour prendre
toutes mesures sociales qui pourraient
l'aider enfin il faut rappeler aux
adolescentes qu'il existe afin de la
formation sexuelle où elles peuvent
trouver tous les renseignements
nécessaires et comme de nombreuses
provinciales ont demandé maintenant des
centres s'ouvre en province notamment à
lille fire appelé la régie renault et
l'artiste ce sera le titre d'une
histoire que nous allons vous raconter
nous allons devoir tout à l'heure avec
paul lefèvre elle pose un certain nombre
de problèmes juridiques
alors je résume il ya cinq ans pierre
dreyfus le pdg de la régie signe un
contrat avec le sculpteur jean dubuffet
pour la construction de ce que l'on
appelait le salon d'été une vaste
construction qui est faite de reliefs
sculptés devant les bâtiments de la
direction générale et puis les travaux
commencent mais il y a trois ans pierre
dreyfus cède sa place à bernard dernier
palier et le nouveau pdg de la régie qui
n'aime pas tellement cette sculpture
interrompt les travaux ensuite cette
halle un doublé ce qui va vous la
raconte et afin d'interrompre les
travaux monsieur bernier paliès invoque
deux raisons tout d'abord la mauvaise
qualité des matériaux utilisés
l'argument sera démentie plus tard par
l'architecte experts monsieur jacques
robin
ensuite la réalisation coûte trop cher
jean dubuffet propose alors à la régie
d'achever l'oeuvre à ses frais pas de
réponse
jean dubuffet porte l'affairé en justice
et perd son procès c'est un signe de la
désaffection qui se manifeste dans notre
société spécialement en france depuis la
guerre à l'égard des oeuvres d'art et
des productions de l'esprit les les
classes dirigeantes actuellement depuis
la guerre en france non plus de
considération que pour les profit
pécuniaire et les promotions sociales et
ne porte plus aucun aucune considération
ni aucune affection aux
réduction de l'esprit qui sont
considérés comme des balivernes
puisqu'il n'est plus question de
matériaux ni de prix qu'il est peut être
question de goût alors qu'est ce qui
empêcherait la régie renault de
débarrasser son terrain privé de ce qui
choque son regard dérange ses habitudes
notre droit n'admet pas eux ayant vendu
une statue on est en même temps autorisé
celui qu'il achetait à la piétiner à la
briser à la démolir et pour assurer
cette protection de l'auteur on a créé
ce qu'on appelle le droit moral qui
comme son nom l'indiqué se distingue
bien du droit corporelle du droit
matériel est ce le droit moral doit
l'emporter toujours devrait l'emporter
lorsque précisément et c'est là qu'on
passe du débat juridique aux débats de
société
dans la pratique on voit trop souvent
que entre l'art et l'industrie
celui qui fait le poids c'est
l'industriel ça n'est pas l'artiste
maître kiejman estime que la justice a
interprété la loi en décrétant que
l'oeuvre véritable de jean dubuffet
c'était cette maquette de plâtre
l'oeuvre en cours de réalisation n'étant
qu'une simple reproduction la régie
renault a donc obtenu l'autorisation
d'enterrer la reproduction
jean dubuffet fait appel la question
qu'il pose est fondamental faut-il
désormais considérée comme n'étant pas
des oeuvres d'art certains objets se
trouvant dans nos musées sous prétexte
qu'ils ont été reproduits à partir des
esquisses ou de maquettes
alors évidemment vais me poser mais la
direction de la régie renault n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions et je
crois qu'il faut dire le fait qu'au-delà
du droit il ya tout problème de
l'héritage artistique de la propriété
véritable savon le premier danger les
juges de la première chambre de la cour
d'appel vont avoir à ce don à se
prononcer sur le problème de fond du
droit moral de l'artiste et ils vont le
faire en délibéré dans quelques semaines
bien sûr ça peut apparaître futile a
beaucoup mais la justice dans un cas
comme celui ci doit assumer un rôle
délicat c'est à dire décider aujourd'hui
à travers le droit qu'elle peut être
l'art le bon goût l'héritage artistique
pour demain une décision à double
tranchant qui pourrait soit permettre je
prends un exemple dans le passé le non
achèvement de la tour eiffel ou alors la
construction dans l'autre sens d'une
horaires fondamentaux
devant laquelle les générations qui
suivent pour et passerez en se pliant
drilles du north of maman avait géré des
donneurs vous prenez on sait tous la
même chose alors il existe une
collection innombrables dans les muses
dans les musées d'oeuvre conakry mortels
et des générations d'hommes de bonne foi
ont sans doute envoyer souvent au pilon
des musiques des sculptures des
peintures qui serait aujourd'hui c'est
d'exister notre enrichissement alors la
création et l as viola bleus celui qui
passe commande at il le droit de démolir
et surtout l'artiste est il seul juge de
la culture bien voilà trois questions
auxquelles vont avoir à répondre dans
quelques semaines les juges de la cour
d'appel de paris et ce n'est pas facile
et puis cette décision de la première
chambre du tribunal de grande instance
de paris la compagnie air france s'est
déclarée responsable des dommages causés
à deux passagers par le fameux
détournement d'un bébé une décision
intéressante qui peut faire
jurisprudence sport maintenant avec la
défaite du français alain marion en boxe
champion d'europe des poids welters
après un dramatique combat face à
l'allemand york eeple alain marion a
perdu hier soir sa couronne au danemark
battu vouvoyait par ko par le danois
joergensen et puis dans quelques minutes
va commencer une soirée décisive pour le
championnat de france de football nous
ne sommes plus qu'à deux matches de la
fin et là notre deuxième journal je
pense que gérard holtz pourra peut-être
vous dire qui de monaco ou de nantes
gagnera françois mauriac rentrer dans la
prestigieuse collection de la pléiade
est toujours un événement le premier
volume de ses oeuvres complètes vient de
sortir tranché rose et papier bible et
puis ce numéro de l'opinion française en
1077 de la sofres très intéressant aussi
faut quand même que je vous dise aussi
que le manneken pis a été retrouvé je
vous le dis et je pense que c'est le
troisième et dernier épisode pour la
semaine en tout cas les auteurs du rapt
était tout simplement des étudiants
d'une école technique de bruxelles ils
ont dû travailler trois nuits
consécutives vous allez voir ça derrière
moi
trois nuits pour essayer déboulonner
c'est arrivé d'ailleurs
le déboulonner le petit bonhomme de son
socle ils ont quand même cette nuit
prévenu de confier sont venus récupérer
l'orgueil de tout à l'heure je voudrais
terminer ce journal par une grande
production de notre service économique
sur la guerre de l'escargot une
véritable bataille rangée à coups de
cornes que se livrent les gastéropodes
français et étrangers les français sont
en train de se faire déborder par les
adversaires mais il faut tenir car sur
le front de la grenouille de l'écrevisse
du foie gras et du champignon vous savez
que les tricolores ont perdu beaucoup de
terrain depuis quelques années leurs
philippe sassier va nous raconter tout
ça cet escargot de bourgogne ne le sait
pas encore mais il est en perte de
vitesse d'escargot est un animal qui
voyagent de plus en plus et les
bourguignons viennent souvent d'europe
centrale
mais ils appartiennent tous à la même
famille cette gloire de la cuisine
française doit souvent croisé les cornes
avec un envahisseurs venus de turquie
aujourd'hui le danger est plus grave le
voici
c'est la cathine à fully qu'à un
escargot chinois ce à quoi qui ressemble
autant à celle d'un escargot de
bourgogne que la cathédrale de reims et
une pagode les il coûte trois fois moins
cher et puis au fond d'une boîte de
conserve tous les escargots paraissent
frais les français s'inquiètent beaucoup
de ce péril jaune au royaume des
gastéropodes
ils sont d'autant plus inquiet que les
braves est bourguignon recule devant le
nombre d'éco qui venus d'asie les scavo
pullulent en chine
c'est même un envahisseur et lescar et
les chinois essaye de s'en débarrasser
par tous les moyens
alors ils s'en débarrassent en ou les
envoyant pour une forte partie ils en
mangent ailleurs ils en mangent eu une
bonne part les aidants expédie une autre
part et ce qui leur fait rentrer des
devises
qu'est ce qu'ils mangent des escargots
actuellement dans le monde dans le monde
après nous ce sont les états unis le
canada l'allemagne l'italie le royaume
uni qui vient doucement cerveau chinois
vous enlever beaucoup de parts de marché
à l'exportation de lens qui nous
concerne nous exportions 50 % de notre
production
et nous sommes tombés à 10% il n'espère
on tue que 5 % pour les années à venir
il est bon c'est espère réussir sur le
plan gastronomique disons que qui nous
quittons douteux y'a que par rapport un
bourgogne une supporte pas la
comparaison
c'est ce cargo c'est moins important
c'est la machine outil mais ce n'est pas
une raison pour rester dans sa coquille
et surprend les escargots les yeux
[ __ ]
alors la bande dessinée maintenant elle
paraît en plein boom elle j'ai là trois
nouveaux journaux à suivre bd et puis
regard sur le monde et pourtant l'âge
d'or de la bande dessinée par est
dépassée elle tâtonne en ce moment elle
se cherche on le verra ce week-end
encore à toulouse où se tient un
festival fini les super héros
martine laroche-joubert a trouvé ceux
d'aujourd'hui 100 muscle un petit peu
dérisoire souvent punk bref la bd n'est
plus ce qu'elle était après l'explosion
des années 60 la bande dessinée semble
manquer de potion magique les années 60
entraînés par un petit gaulois décaper
par l'humour acide a atterri elle avait
quitté la chambre d'enfant pour le salon
et c'est de retrouver éléments de notre
culture quotidienne
les dessinateurs de bd ce qui s'est
penché sur la société en deux temps vos
idées par le fenêtre de notre train de
vie emporté croyait-il vers une nouvelle
société d'après mai 68 se retrouve
aujourd'hui sur un butoir la réalité
couleurs crise les héros sont tristes
leur aventure où la couleur des
murailles peut-être que cette espèce de
situation ne peut plus vaseuses se
retrouve dans mes personnages dans la
psychologie des personnages qui
généralement sont des perdants sont des
personnages sans espoir et encore une
fois qu'ils contrôlent pas du tout ce
qui se passe autour d'eux atmosphère
oppressante ou dans la bande dessinée
d'aujourd'hui les héros ce qui nous
ressemble
ce qui pourrait marcher dans les rues
avec nous son petit petits bonshommes
entouré de brand grands ensembles grands
personnages et même quand la bd devient
plus politique plus proche de nos
préoccupations actuelles
alors là c'est pire les héros nos frères
de vienne me dont 3 de rapaces
dans dans la bande des ballons noirs il
ya aussi des politicards véreux il ya
aussi des gens qui font des promesses
pour le changement qui promettent par
exemple de débarrasser les moutons du
baron noir
et puis il ya des prétendants au pouvoir
qui disent vous n'avez rien fait jusqu'à
présent
moi je vous débarrasserez du baron noir
alors voilà alors tourner autour de
cette idée là quel est le plus menteur
les deux devant l'absence de rêve sur la
réalité
les dessinateurs se réfugient dans les
aventures dans les grands ailleurs de la
science fiction mais aussi dans les
brumes des légendes dans la mémoire des
régions bande bretonne bones occitane et
c'est là la grande force de la bd être
le récipient privilégié des diverses et
courants qui ne pourraient s'exprimer
ailleurs mais je crois que la banque
bretonne que nous faisons est actuel
c'est pour ça que le premier épisode se
passe dans le présent c'est pour bien
montrer que les problèmes ont toujours
été les mêmes et que malheureusement ils
sont encore les mêmes 2001 après c'est
un problème de de pression des minorités
quelle qu'elle soit par une majorité qui
peut être une majorité militaires ou
politiques ou géographiques
qu'elles soient chaque mois par est un
millier de pages de bd titre qui se font
et se défont devant cette impression de
tourner en rond devant la grisaille
apparaît une tentation tout faire
éclater tout nié le récit la page
les dessins exception de quelques
dessinateurs toujours les mêmes qui
songent pas riser gb mandryka tout le
reste me paraît plat conformiste sans
intérêt les seuls vrais créateurs c'est
justement
des jeunes gens qui n'échappe pas à la
moss faire du mouvement qui sont dedans
totalement ils ont produit des dessins
ses dessins sont une parodie de cette
époque puisque il décale ce qui existe
et en décalquant il le parasite est
à telle enseigne qu'aujourd'hui on peut
dire que leur influence est considérable
ces bandes sont les premières bandes
peintes comme il ya une musique punk le
hard rock le rock dur c'est la bd dure
celle qui naît dans les lycées et pour
astérix la potion aurait un goût amer
peut-être l'amertume de se sentir venir
l'anr page de notre journal la météo il
fera beau sur le sud est du pays après
dissipation des brouillards matinaux
les températures seront en hausse sur le
reste de la france quelques ondées
orageuses de la bretagne à l'aquitaine
alterneront avec des exercices sur ces
régions les températures varieront peu
n'oubliez pas demain samedi ennemis en
direct de nice notre rendez vous avec
des surdoués jean claude mongeau et à sa
nombre d'invités et puis auparavant en
un dernier rendez vous pour la journée
avec l'actualité c'est à 22h45 c'est
gérard holtz qui vous présentera la
dernière édition faute à tous une
excellente de fin de soirée à l'écouté
de nos programmes
merci de votre attention